All right, I get the hint.
You actually want
this class to be finished
sometime before the next
Android release happens.
We're almost done.
So we look in
ForecastFragment in onStart.
We've actually been cheating a bit.
Every single time we get to onStart,
we actually update the weather.
Let's get rid of that.
It'll force us to actually have to use
the refresh function
to get new weather,
but it'll help illustrate
the cool stuff
we're about to do with preferences.
We're going to stop cheating here.
In onPreferenceChange,
if we're not actually binding preferences,
we're going to execute
a new FetchWeatherTask,
if there's a change in location.
Otherwise, we'll just notify
our CONTENT_URI
to allow our cursor to update.
We still have to do one more thing.
In ForecastFragment,
we've been using an instance variable,
mLocation, to save
the preferred location we get
when we're actually an onCreate loader.
We've been doing that
because we've been planning
to use this for a while.
Let's override another function.
In onResume, we need to check to see
whether or not
our location has changed.
So if our location is not equal to null,
and Utility.getPreferredLocation
does not equal location,
well, then we can
call update weather.
Let's see what happens.
You see it immediately changed back.
You didn't see that loading
because it didn't have to load anything.
However, if we change settings
to something else,
it's refreshed in the background.
Well, it turns out updating weather
doesn't actually help us here.
Why?
Because our URI hasn't changed.
Remember, we're doing
everything based upon URI.
What we really need to do
is reset our loader.
So, how do we do that?
Well, it's pretty straightforward.
Just like we did in onActivityCreated,
we have to use LoaderManager.
So instead of calling updateWeather,
what we're actually going to do
is call something else.
In this case, not an initLoader,
but restartLoader.
It takes the same parameters
as an initLoader.
Now, let's try this again.
That already looks better.
All right, let's change back
to our own weather again.
And there we are.
As you can see,
the weather is changing as we go
from location to location,
but we still have this problem.
Obviously, when we change settings here,
it doesn't affect anything.
So we need to fix that.
That's where you come in.